welcome to this video playing iteration
Massa sombra some bra bra bra bra no
name yeah I don't know why the flexor
are gone can the weird ok we have ac45
opening English and I went form the
bishop before based setup that's kind of
similar to the Russell emo Russell emo
reversed in fact I don't know it I had
to know that line really too well rookie
ad for all those are moves but what is
always some kind of comforting in a way
this all is very natural you can develop
pieces and well it just looks like you
can find good moves without knowing
anything ok 95 I guess I should keep
this Bishop and now I think age 6
doesn't make sense doing one Bishop g5
to happen and then maybe like d 6 a-6 p
should be six yeah looks like normal
very normal moves I am A five or not
yeah not quite sure if this is good a
five or a six okay absorbs let's check
t6 not the Queen
yeah an interesting question is if I
really should take on his seven at one
point or not I can also just play Bishop
e6 this kind of this kind of move righty
to maybe I don't know but this looks
kind of normal Jack so what is he up
what what is he going to do 94 maybe so
maybe just drop back on the move like 94
i also have bishop deform i am f for SF
for the plan kind of guessing here what
White's idea might be rabid at for us
and for really looks strange
okay now yes he has prevented them with
d5 that that is pretty clear so if I go
nite a bishop d4 and I take on c3 will
probably take with the pawn okay I'll
move on Eirik on EA this ridiculous so
doing here to have f5 prepared
ok Knight f3 I have Bishop e3 and that's
an important little point ok yeah I mean
I have to trade this that is that's
absolutely out of the question the
bishop on c3 has to go
now okay after the bishop trades he's
able to put something on g1 but still
the bishop 1c3 is so strong so it's a
piece that you really have to trade
there is no no way around that problem
yeah it's not easy not an easy position
so he's operating with the idea to
capture them ok I can take first and now
queen f six maybe hmm i don't know Queen
f6 he might have G form
okay let's go here
now why just what oh that's very
surprising I was really thinking he has
to keep keep things on the board I can
take on 85 for Bishop g5 just tactic
just a tactic okay how stupid now okay
oh it's not doing that surprising
okay he's hurtin in d5 so have to have
to react here if I've him
Wow
well as very that's a very very
problematic position here well okay you
can go d 585 that's not good not good at
all
whoa
yeah that is a huge huge bone on e6 Wow
all right night on c5 is doing pretty
much nothing and this looks ugly I know
that if he goes h 5 i'm completely
falling apart I mean probably i'm
falling apart anyway but if i allow h4
h5 @ season goes to show page three and
then you will take that i have to play
rogue f8 I guess f8 end and f6 stupid
sugar 3 is just completely winning that
that may be also ig6 is just attacked
come on time morning Wow okay look f6 it
is a total disaster this position
amazing
my motto for draw here if you can I can
probably win on time maybe I'm
checkmated before that am i checkmated
maybe add a little loopy singing come on
this is the kind of thing is so slow
that i will probably really win on time
right Janice's made yeah come on it I am
what a waterbody game him wow that I
didn't I didn't even think about the
Queen trade Chandler it is strong and he
also he could have taken here with rinse
the exchange but he didn't do that I
mean I don't know if he if he didn't see
the move or if he just came to the
conclusion that D for a stronger which
is probably true ID after d 4 i'm in
huge trouble I'm really this is this is
this is terribly bad he gets a five and
d5 in now let's just lost candy it's
just losing this pollution and so what
what happened here what went wrong in
this position probably I really don't he
probably I shouldn't take this is some
this is probably what I should do I
really don't think I'm substantially
worse yeah that would be kind of
surprising a computer is on equal 0 0 0
so as funny huh looks like it is a dead
draw or anything but it isn't it's just
yeah Jack yeah amazing how bad this is
maybe Bishop kicks and the compounds to
tip with a king but it is no big
difference right
this is so this is actually somewhat
better then this is actually somewhat
better than what I had in the game this
is not even a big issue we are now the
night is a very nice bloke ADA this
might be okay actually I can may set up
a pretty reliable kind of fortress it's
it's entirely passive but that wasn't
one wrong arrow yeah I mean a light like
this and this is this is debris it's
better I am I was still thinking of when
I when we were here I didn't really I
didn't see how strong this was and here
i was thinking of putting the night on
c5 but the night only seven assists just
the better the better locator yeah this
is just lost him he's putting or
everything that there is on the porn
okay I can of course I should protect
you six but i was already this is just
terrible wow that was very nicely played
with the with the big centum okay thanks
for watching